yeah hello and welcome to this video
we'll just mark two six six four oh
let's see what he does
okay nos dyslexia and ethics oh my god
is it going for the hippo the scary
hippo almost looks like it and I'm just
doing it like in the same issue same ish
Kings again I don't know he does attack
the center interesting I mean maybe just
f3 I'm not sure how good is Sicilian
that is if you take so he doesn't want
to take okay okay let's now do go ahead
[Music]
hmm see takes also looks quite good
hmm both looks good okay so he will take
a now yep
play the other night I just have more
space in this position so it should be a
comfortable situation for me maybe just
wait there
I want to take David oh I did not pay
attention to this
hmm that's not good it's not good that
I'd neglected this possibility here
check
where do you go with the Queen to f4
it's the only square left
Finkle g4 register Queen go
black resigns okay how long did you take
for that one second and two seconds for
this and then the Queen was gone
yeah once in a while anyway
I'm not too happy with this because that
opening I should get some advantage and
I didn't get much i completely forgot
about b5m it wasn't wasn't probably all
that great I mean I'm not the worst but
yeah it really isn't all that much 5a
Bishop d7 was taking away the final
square with Knights coming this way I
have some play against the spawn the
long diagonal is quite good but I
thought I should have had more actually
so Queen d7 is best and then there are
ideas here on the long diagonal yeah
this is better for whites but again I
felt I gave them something okay thanks
for watching